SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BROUGH
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEAM
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO A QUORUM IS PRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE. RAY HAS
ONLY BECAUSE- WITH WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OCEAN
FROM NEXT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. FOR OVER
FIVE THOUSAND YEARS NO WORRIES
THE PERSON YOU YEARS HAS BEEN
CELEBRATED WITH THE COMING OF
SPRING. FROM DECEMBER THE LONG
WINTER NIGHTS SLOWLY SHORTEN
UNTIL THE DAYS AND NIGHTS ARE
EQUAL IN LENGTH. THE WORLD
FEELS UNCOMFORTABLE BALANCE AND
HARMONY EVERY SPRING MARKS THE
RENEWING OF THE WORLD. TENDER
GREEN MEANS THING SHOOTS EMERGE
FROM THEIR BRANCHES IN EMPTY
FIELDS A NEW SEASON OF GROWTH
BEGINS AND WITH IT THE HOPE FOR
A BOUNTIFUL YEAR. DURING A RUSE
ALL THE WORLD SEEMS TO BE
MANIFESTING THE MIRACLE OF
LIFE. IN OUR APPRECIATION FOR
ALL LIFE IS RENEWED AS WE
WITNESS THE BEAUTY OF NEW LIFE
EMERGING ALL AROUND US. NOW
MOMMY NUMBERS WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS AREA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER NAZARIAN. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND. IT IS A LITTLE. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY RECENTLY MET AT NINE A.
M. UNTIL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM THIS ON THE PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK SUPER CRAP THE DESK
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND
LOUIS READING THE REBELS CALLED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE AND
THE DECORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY
MOTION CARRIED TIME NINE OH
NINE AM THE SPEAKER PRO TEM
DIRECTED THE SENATE SERGEANT
ARMS TO CLOSE THE DOORS AND TO
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT
NINE SIXTEEN AM SPEAKER PRO TEM
MELINDA KARAKORAM OF THE SIMPLY
PRESENT THE ROLES COMPLETED THE
FOLLOWING ANSWER TO THEIR NAMES
ARE CURRY AROUND HER BONTA
MOVES AND MISTER FLORA SECONDS
OF THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS. WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES. AND
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
SOME THE MEMBERS THE SYRIAN AND
RAY AS TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. THANK YOU I
MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX TO WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ORDER THEM TO
SECOND READING ASSEMBLY BILLS
ONE EIGHT SIX THREE THROUGH ONE
NINE ZERO TWO. INCLUSIVE THANK
YOU MISTER BONTA MISTER FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE SIR YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLDING APPS
CONSENT NATURAL CALL VOTE.
MISTER FLORA IS WITHHOLDING IN
THIS CASE MISTER BONTA MOVES
AND MR HOLDEN SECONDS ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. CLARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ISSUE
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. MR BONTA IS ASKING
FOR AN I. MISTER FLOORS ASKING
FOR NO. THIS TAKES FORTY ONE ON
THE ROLE SUSPENSION. IT'S A
SIMPLE NUMBERS GAME AT. THERE
MR BONTA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MISS FLORES ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. MY LITTLE JOB. THE
CLERK WILL DO WE WENT TO BE
CLOSER ROLE EYES FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MR BONTA YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR STONE FROM THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE NUMEROUS
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. MS AGUIAR-CURRY I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
INTRODUCE MY FIVE DISTRICT
OFFICE INTERNS HERE TODAY IN
THE GALLERY ALL OF THEM ARE
STUDENTS AT UC DAVIS AND THE
COMPLETED A QUARTER LONG
INTERNSHIP IN MY DAVIS OFFICE
FOR TEN WEEKS. THAT WE HAVE
WITH US UNTIL THE CYBER
SILVERSTEIN GABRIEL ACOSTA
GARCIA RAMONA MORA MY A DOUBLE
ROW SO AM I CAME ALL THE LET'S
GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU. AND MR
GRAYSON YES SPECIAL GAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY GALLERY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE WITH US
TODAY IN EIGHTH GRADE CLASS
FROM QUEEN OF ALL SAINTS SCHOOL
WHICH IS LOCATED IN CONCORD
THEY MAKE AN ANNUAL TRIP TO THE
STATE CAPITOL TO LEARN ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
THEY ARE HERE WITH US TODAY IN
THE GALLERY RIGHT ABOVE ME
HERE- FRIENDS COLLEAGUES PLEASE
TAKE A MOMENT TO JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THESE GUESTS. TO THE
CALIFORNIA SEVEN.
I AM MR
GLORIA. MEMBERS. MR GLORIA YOUR
GUESTS ARRIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- PROUD TO RISE TO
INTERVIEW SEVEN SEVEN MEMBERS
OF THE LYMPHATIC EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH NETWORK CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER- THESE REPRESENTATIVE
COME FROM DIFFERENT CITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. CORONADO DEL
MAR MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AS
WELL AS LOS ANGELES AND FROM
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THESE
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO BRING AWARENESS
TO THE DISEASE OF THE DEMON- IN
CALIFORNIA CALLING TO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
THANKING THEM FOR THEIR WORK
AND ALL THAT THEY DO AND OF
COURSE TWENTY MINUTE MAKING
SURE THAT WE DO MORE TO COMBAT
THAT THE DEMON. THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I AM PROUD
TO WELCOME STUDENTS AND STAFF.
WITH THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. SEATED UP IN THE
GALLERY. WE HAVE STUDENTS FROM
ACROSS ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES FOR THEIR ADVOCACY DAY.
CAL STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION
IS A STUDENT LED ORGANIZATION
THAT STRIVES TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS BY
ADVOCATING FOR STUDENTS NEEDS
AND ENGAGING STUDENTS AND
SYSTEM WIDE STATE AND FEDERAL
HIGHER EDUCATION POLICY MAKING
MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME AND
WELCOMING THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU THE CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AGRICULTURAL LEADERSHIP
CLASS UP THERE IN THE GALLERY
WAVE HI. BECAUSE OF THEIR
IMPRESSIVE BACKGROUNDS AND
ACADEMIC ACCOMPLISHMENTS THESE
TWENTY STUDENTS WERE SELECTED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
AS PART OF THE PROGRAM THE
STUDENTS RESEARCH SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES. IMPACTING CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND
THEY'LL BE PRESENTING THE
RESULTS TODAY AT FOUR PM IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR. ALSO
JOINING INSTANCES THEIR
PROFESSOR DR MARK SHELTON WHO'S
DEDICATED HIS CAREER TO
DEVELOPING THE NEXT GENERATION
OF AGRICULTURAL LEADERS MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING THEM A
WARM WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
AND MISS RAY YES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MS RAMOS
MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISS RAY S. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
AND TO CELEBRATE THAT IT IS
WITH GREAT PLEASURE AND HONOR
THAT I INTRODUCED THE
INCREDIBLE HISTORY MAKING CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO WOMEN'S
VOLLEYBALL TEAM TO YOU. THESE
THESE STUDENT ATHLETES ALONG
WITH THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND SEE A DIVISION TWO NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP. THE UNIVERSITY'S
FIRST EVER NATIONAL TITLE. AND
I SAY IT WAS THE WOMEN WHO WANT
THAT FIRST TITLE. WITH THE
THIRTY THREE ZERO RECORD THE
COYOTES MDE A PERFECT SEASON
AND ARE RANKED NUMBER ONE IN
THE NATION. THIS TEAM STORY IS
ONE OF HARD WORK PERSEVERANCE
AND FRIENDSHIP THEY CONTINUE TO
PUSH ONE ANOTHER TO BECOME
BETTER EVERY SINGLE DAY. I'M
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THEIR
PASSION AND DEDICATION TO
EXCELLENCE. CONGRATULATIONS TO
ALL OF THE GRADUATING SENIORS
OF THIS TEAM AS YOU EMBARK ON
THE NEXT CHAPTER I WISH FOR YOU
THE VERY BEST OF LUCK. AND FOR
THOSE WHO STILL HAVE SOME MORE
TIME ON THE TEAM I KNOW THIS IS
ONLY THE BEGINNING OF MANY
MONUMENTAL ACHIEVEMENTS. THANK
YOU TO AMAZING COACHING STAFF
FOR HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF HARD WORK COMMITMENT
TO PRACTICE I WISH YOU MANY
MORE VICTORIES TO COME. ADD TO
PRESIDENT THE MOST MORE ON
THIS. PRESIDENT OF CAL STATE
SAMBAR TO DO YOU KNOW I
CONGRATULATE YOU. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE DEDICATION TO
STUDENT SUCCESS. VERY
SPECIFICALLY MEMBERS. HEAD
COACH KIM SURENESS FROM MY
DISTRICT. THE ASSISTANT COACH.
ALEXIS DOES. KATIE SCOTT. JENNY
LIND HAYES. ONE OF MY ALL.
SALAS DOMINIQUE. VICE PRESIDENT
OF STUDENT AFFAIRS POSSIBLE THE
BADDEST. DIRECTOR OF ATHLETICS
SHOWN PEROT. AND UP IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE OUR GREAT
PHOTOGRAPHERS OF THE LEGAL.
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS MY DEAR FRIEND PAM
LANKFORD. ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RAY IS FOR RECOGNIZING-
THE WOMEN'S VOLLEYBALL TEAMS GO
ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE THERE.
THIS ONE IS A GRADUATE ALL THE
TEAM MEMBERS IN THE COACHES FOR
THE STOP STRONG SUPPORT- IN THE
BENCH OF FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY. A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO JUNIOR
ALEXIS FOR THOSE- BECAUSE SHE'S
COMING BACK AS A SENIOR NEXT
YEAR SO LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. THEY'RE THE ONLY TEAM
TO MOVE FORWARD UNDEFEATED. IN
THIS AREA IN THE NCAA AND CAL%
STATE SUMMER DINOS. FIRST
CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM LET'S GIVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE. PERCENT OUR
STATE UNIVERSITY SEVENTEEN ALL
WHICH WE SHARE WITH A LOT OF
THE CONSTITUENTS GOING THERE
AND WE OURSELVES ARE ONE THE
GRADUATED FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SABATINO SO GO
COYOTES. AND THERE IS AS THEY
SAY YEAH CAL STATE SENATOR DO
YOU KNOW I GOT A LOOK ON THIS
BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE SAID TO.
RIGHT ON BUT THEY SAID NO IT'S
DREAM BIG. AND YOKES.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO AND THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUE. MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. H. R. SEVENTY
EIGHT BY MISTER IN THIS AREA
AND THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO KNOW RUSE.
MISTER IS THERE ANY MAIL BUT ON
THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT HR
SEVENTY EIGHT. AN API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HOUSE
RESOLUTION TO COMMEMORATE MARCH
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AS THE
BEGINNING OF KNOWS. THE PERSIAN
NEW YEAR NOTICES A COMBINATION
OF TO FORESEE WORDS THE FIRST
WORD NO MEANS NEW AND THE
SECOND WORD RUSE. MEANS DAY
TOGETHER THE WORD MEANS NEW DAY
WHICH IS THE NAME GIVEN TO THE
NEW YEAR IN THE PERSIAN
CALENDAR. NO NEWS IS A THREE
THOUSAND YEAR OLD PERSIAN
TRADITION WHICH CELEBRATES BOTH
THE NATURAL AND SPIRITUAL
RENEWAL SPRING BRINGS AND
EXTENDS ITS HOPE FOR PEACE
SOLIDARITY AT NEW BEGINNINGS
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. NOTICES
CELEBRATED BY PEOPLE'S OF MANY
DIFFERENT RELIGIONS AND
CULTURES ACROSS A VAST REGION
OVER LAST MILLENNIA NOTICE HAS
DEVELOPED AND EXPANDED
INCORPORATING NEW SOCIAL
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURE WELL IN
FOR THE TRADITIONS AND CUSTOMS
THE COMPANY THE CELEBRATION
NOTE IS VERY FROM THE COUNTRY
TO. THERE ARE MANY UNIFIED
FEATURES MOST TICKET. HAVE
TABLE ON WHICH A NUMBER OF
SYMBOLIC. ARE PLACED THESE
ANNUAL. TO WELCOME SPRING HAVE
BEEN PASSED ON FROM GENERATION
TO GENERATION THROUGHOUT THE
LAST MILLENNIUM. NOTICE
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY NOT
ONLY TO ENJOY ANCIENT CULTURE
CUSTOMS AND TRADITIONAL SONGS
MUSIC DANCING RITUALS FOODS AND
STORYTELLING BUT ALSO TO
PROMOTE PEACE AND SOLIDARITY
WITHIN TOWNS AND COMMUNITIES
AND TO STRENGTHEN DEEP ROOTED
BONDS OF FRIENDSHIP AND
EXCHANGE. TODAY'S FOCUS ON
RECONCILIATION AND
NEIGHBORLINESS CONTRIBUTE TO
CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND
COOPERATION AMONG PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
BACKGROUNDS COMMEMORATING NOTED
WAS ALWAYS OF. ALL ALLOWS US TO
BREAK DOWN SOME OF THE WALLS
OTHERS WOULD TRY TO PUT IN
PLACE BY REVEALING OUR COMMON
HUMANITY. THANK YOU NOTICE
PETERS TALL CELEBRATING HERE
AND AROUND THE STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
DOCTOR CHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF H. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT CELEBRATING MARCH
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AT THE
BEGINNING A NO GROUPS THE
PERSIAN NEW YEAR NO WILL
PROMOTES PEACE AND SOLIDARITY
WALMART IN THE FIRST DAY OF
SPRING THE RENEWAL OF NATURE.
ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNIST RENT AND
PERSONAL BONTA FAMILY FOR.
THANK YOU FOR TIME SPEAKER AND
I RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND MR GABRIEL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY EIGHT AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION LIKE THE GLOBAL
JEWISH COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA'S
JEWISH COMMUNITY IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE AND INCLUDES TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SEPHARDIC AND
MIZRAHI JEWS WHO PROBABLY TRACE
THEIR ROOTS BACK TO THE MIDDLE
EAST AND NORTH AFRICA AND THIS
INCLUDES A LARGE AND VIBRANT
VERSION JEWISH COMMUNITY WAS
CELEBRATE SNOW ROUTES. THANKS
TO A NEW GENERATION OF
ACTIVISTS WHO ARE PROBABLY
EMBRACING THEIR MULTIPLE
IDENTITIES THESE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE BECOMING MORE
SPECIFICALLY AND POLITICALLY
ENGAGED AND BRINGING THEIR
UNIQUE HISTORY AND PERSPECTIVE
INTO OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS I
AM PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT A
LARGE AND VIBRANT PERSON JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND A PERSON
COMMUNITY OF MANY DIFFERENT
FACE IN THE WEST SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND I'M USED TO JOIN
THEM IN CELEBRATING A RUSE AND
THE BEGINNING OF SPRING AND THE
RIVER REBIRTH OF NATURE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY MENTIONED SPIRIT OF NO.
WE HAVE ANSWER WE EMBRACE
CHANGE IN OUR OWN LIVES. AND TO
RENEW OUR FOCUS ON THE WORK OF
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND UPLIFTING THOSE
IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN
NEED OF HELP. IN THAT SPIRIT I
WISH EVERYONE HERE AND AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
CELEBRATES EIGHT NO RUSE MY BY
ROCK AND A NEW ROSE. HEROES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON HR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL
THIS FRIEDMAN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I'M PROUD
TO RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY EIGHT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT MEMBERS WE ARE
LIVING IN DIFFICULT TIMES AT
HOME AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
GLOBE. THE CONFUSION THE DEVICE
TO VISIT MISS THE CONFLICT. AND
THE HATRED THREATENS TO
OVERWHELM US ALL. THE RUSE IS A
REMINDER THAT EVEN IN OUT OF
THE DARKEST DAYS THERE IS
LIGHT. AT ITS CORE IT'S A
CELEBRATION OF RENEWAL. THE
MESSAGE OF PEACE MUTUAL RESPECT
AND SOLIDARITY BETWEEN
GENERATIONS AND COMMUNITIES HAS
NEVER BEEN MORE TIMELY THAN IT
IS TODAY. TODAY WE MARK THE NEW
BEGINNING OFFERED BY NO ROOFS
AND WISH EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND
ALL THOSE WHO CELEBRATE ACROSS
THE NATION AND AROUND THE
WORLD. A PROSPEROUS AND A SWEET
NEW YEAR THAT WOULD HELP LOVE
JOY AND PEACE I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON HR SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MR HOLDEN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBER FROM
VAN NUYS FOR INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION. HOW TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR SEVENTY EIGHT
COMMEMORATING MARCH NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY AS THE BEGINNING
OF NO ROOFS THE PERSIAN NEW
YEAR. A THREE THOUSAND YEAR OLD
PERSIAN TRADITION NORRIS'S
CELEBRATED BY PEOPLE OF MANY
DIFFERENT RELIGIONS AND
CULTURES ACROSS THE WORLD. IN
MY DISTRICT THE PERSIAN
COMMUNITY HOLE CELEBRATIONS
EACH YEAR THAT WELCOMES THE
LARGER COMMUNITY AND GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND
APPRECIATE CULTURE. OVER
THOUSANDS OF YEARS THE
CELEBRATION OF SPRING RENEWAL
HAS INDOOR AND REMINDING US TO
TAKE TIME TO REMOVE HARMFUL OR
NEGATIVE THINGS FROM OUR LIVES.
MORE THAN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SPRING CLEANING THIS IS THE
TIME TO EXAMINE WHAT IS TRULY
IMPORTANT TO US. NO ROOTS ALSO
BRINGS HOPE FOR PEACE AND
SOLIDARITY. SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA AND THIS COUNTRY
TRULY NEEDS TODAY. WHICH IS WHY
I AM ENCOURAGED TO KNOW THAT
TODAY'S FOCUS WILL BE ON
RECONCILIATION AND NEIGHBORLY
NEIGHBORHOOD LISTS. TO PROMOTE
COOPERATION AND DIVERSITY. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR SEVENTY EIGHT IN CELEBRATION
OF NOWRUZ. YOU KNOW ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I RISE AND SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR PARTNER AND
OUR FRIEND FROM VAN NUYS WHO
SEVERAL IN SEVEN YEARS AGO
REMINDED US OF BROUGHT THIS
PARTICULAR CELEBRATION TO THIS
HOUSE AND SOME OF YOU WERE NOT
HERE AT THAT TIME WITH THOSE OF
US WHO WERE LEARN SOMETHING NEW
ABOUT A CULT IN A TRADITION
THAT WE DID NOT KNOW. AND
FORTUNATELY TO REMAIN IN THE
HOUSE FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS
ONCE AGAIN REMINDING US OF THE
COMMONALITY OF HUMANITY THAT WE
ALL WANTED THAT WE HAVE
SOMETIMES THE SAME DREAMS AND
ASPIRATIONS OF OTHERS. WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH BECAUSE YOU
REMIND SO MUCH OF THE TRADITION
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS HAD FOR
MANY YEARS YOU WE CELEBRATE NEW
YEAR'S IT ANYWHERE A NEW YEAR
BECAUSE WE IT'S TIME TO BE NEW
SELVES IN ABOUT THE- AND
JANUARY WHAT I'M VERY IMPORTANT
AFRICAN AMERICANS PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO WERE LATE. ALWAYS
FREE. NOT THE THAT WE DO. HAVE
AN- EARLY IN EIGHTY SIXTY.
BECAME A MAJOR PIECE AND
CELEBRATE. AN AFRICAN LIE. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT WE THINK OF OUR
TO. YOU KNOW WHEN I'VE GONE TO
GHANA I'M ALWAYS IMPRESSED BY
SOMETHING CALLED THE FESTIVAL
OF THE GAMES WHICH IS ONCE
AGAIN A KIND OF COMING TOGETHER
IN A HARVEST TIME. FOR
SOMETHING THAT WAS RENEWED BUT
WAS ALSO FOCUS UPON THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE YOURSELF. AND
THAT WOULD MAY HAVE HAPPENED IN
THE PAST HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
AND YOU TRY TO RESURRECT THE
GOODNESS IN YOURSELF TO DEAL
WITH THE PAST BUT ALWAYS MOVING
FORWARD TO A BETTER PLACE. AND
SO THE FESTIVAL OF THE GAMBLERS
ALWAYS AN EXCITING TIME FOR ME.
IT ALSO REMINDS ONE A- IN DATE
IT WAS. QUITE AND EACH ONE
THOSE DAYS. A THE- WHAT WAS
COULD YOU CHAU LEAH WILL JIMA
OLD MO JO ALL THOSE THINGS
TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO CHANGE YOUR WORLD. I GO TO
SHARE YOUR WELL WITH SOMEBODY
ELSE I GOING TO HAVE A BETTER
FUTURE AND A BETTER HOPE IN A
BETTER DREAM. AND SO WHEN I
THINK OF THIS IT REMINDS ME
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ONCE AGAIN TO CHANGE OURSELVES.
THE COMMONALITY OF MAN IS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT HE BELIEVED
THAT THE SPIRIT WITHIN HIMSELF.
ALLOWED HIMSELF TO MOVE FORWARD
TO ONCE AGAIN. CORRECT HIS PAST
WOULD NEVER TO ALLOW THE
PROBLEMS OF THE PAST TO
DETERMINE THE FUTURE. AND
ALWAYS MOVING FORWARD SO ONCE
AGAIN I'M EXCITED ABOUT NO
RULES I WAS HAPPY TO MEET MANY
OF THOSE WHO CAME TODAY FOR THE
CELEBRATION. BECAUSE IT ONCE
AGAIN IF EVEN THOUGH IT'S ONLY
BEEN THREE MONTHS SINCE WE'VE
HAD OUR FIRST NEW YEAR. MOST OF
US HAVE MADE SOME PROBLEM THAT
HAD SOME DIFFICULTY IT IS NICE
TO KNOW THAT EVEN IN MARCH I
CAN RENEW MYSELF AGAIN. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO A SOMEONE
ELSE'S NEW YEAR THAT ALLOWS ME
TO CONTINUALLY WORK OR RENEWING
MYSELF. SO ONCE AGAIN WITH THE
BLACK CAUCUS CELEBRATED H. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM VAN NUYS TO
BRING IT FORWARD AND ALL OF
THOSE WHO COME TODAY TO
CELEBRATE IT AND WE HAVE WHICH
YOU HAPPEN RULES. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS. SEEKING RECOGNITION MR
IS HEARING YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IT'S ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO HAVE
COLLEAGUES GIVE THEIR
PERSPECTIVES- OF THE
CELEBRATION AS WELL AND ALSO
RELATED TO THE CONTEXT THAT OF
THE CULTURES THAT THEY COME
FROM THE HAIL FROM SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR EVERYONE SPOKEN
WORDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. A MISTER
IS THERE ANY WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLE THANK.
MEASURES AREAS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. VERSUS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ADDING ON TO THE RESOLUTION
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLARK WELL CLOSE
RATHER SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ADDED AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. AND MISTER NAZARIAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MY DESK
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
ONE SECOND RIGHT BACK. IN JUST
ONE MOMENT. MR NECESSARY IN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- IT'S- HONOR TO
HAVE A GROUP OF VERY ESTEEMED
INDIVIDUALS OR COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND PROFESSIONALS- FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE JOINING US
TODAY ON THE FLOOR FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO COMMEMORATE THE
NOTICE EVERYONE ON ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE RECEIVED A- HI
ESSENCE WHICH SYMBOLIZES THE
BEAUTY OF THE NEW SEASON IN
YOUR OFFICE THE SMELL AND THE
AROMA WOULD BE A LITTLE TOO
MUCH. IF ALL EIGHTY OF OUR
TABLES HAD WON OVER HERE SO
INSTEAD IT'S A IT'S BEING
DELIVERED TO YOUR OFFICES-
TODAY I AM JOINED BY BY THIS
EIGHT WONDERFUL INDIVIDUALS WHO
SOME OF WHOM HAVE ALREADY BEEN
INTRODUCED- ON ON AN OCCASION
OR TWO BEFORE BUT I WANTED TO
TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE AGAIN- FIRST FOUR AND
FOR MOST JOINING US IS SUSAN AS
HE SAW THE- PRESIDENT OF THE
RUNNING AMERICAN WISH THAT. IN
LOS ANGELES. IT IS END BUT I'D
ASK IS WE HOLD OFF ON PLUS
TOWARDS THE END I SELL. LIVE ON
THE- AND COMMUNITY AND
ACTIVISTS. SAID TARBELL DON.
PERSIAN TV HOST MAJORS FAT HAD
NESSIE FUNNY AND CLOSER OVER A
TOTAL HE- BOTH ARE RETIRED
CHECK JET FIGHTER PILOTS
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND ACTIVISTS
MAGGIE SO FUNNY HOW NEEDY
COMMUNITY LEADER AND A
SUCCESSFUL SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND THE INDIVIDUAL AT THE
IMPETUS BEHIND THE SEVEN YEARS
OF CELEBRATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
HERE. DR NEPTUNE MIZRAHI CHIEF
SCIENTIST OFFICER AT UCLA. SO
GRAY MIZRAHI IMMIGRATION LAW
SPECIALIST AND DR AMIR
COMMITTEE- INTERNATIONAL EXPERT
IN GLOBAL TERRORISM. THANK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. H. R.
EIGHTY FIVE COVERAGE HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO WOMEN AND
GIRLS HIV AIDS AWARENESS DAY.
MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR H. R.
EIGHTY FIVE RECOGNIZING MARCH
TENTH AS WOMEN AND GIRLS HIV
AIDS AWARENESS DAY. THIS YEAR'S
THEME IS HIV PREVENTION STARTS
WITH ME ENDING THE HIV EPIDEMIC
TOGETHER. RECOGNIZING THAT
EVERYONE WOMEN MEN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS THE HIV NEGATIVE
AND THOSE LIVING WITH HIV HAVE
AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY IN
HIV PREVENTION. TOGETHER WE
HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES TOWARDS
PREVENTING THE TRANSMISSION OF
HIV AIDS I'M PARTICULARLY PROUD
OF THE BIPARTISAN EFFORTS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO PREP AND PAP
TREATMENTS. HOWEVER THERE IS
STILL OWN NEARLY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES
DIAGNOSED WITH HIV. AND NEARLY
ONE IN FOUR OF THEM ARE WOMEN.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE
TO DRAW ATTENTION AND FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS AND RESOURCES ON HIV
AIDS AND RAISE AWARENESS FOR
PREVENTION AND EDUCATION FOR
WOMEN. I ASK YOU ALL TO JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING MARCH TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY. AS WOMEN AND
GIRLS HIV AND AIDS AWARENESS
DAY AND ENCOURAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE NECESSARY
STEPS TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
HIV AND AIDS. I WANT TO THANK
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS FOR THEIR
SPONSORSHIP. I ASKED THAT THE
FIRST ROLE WE OPENED FOR CALL
AUTHORS AN URGENT AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON.
THE RESOLUTION MS WALTERS ASSN
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR. EIGHTY FIVE THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. PARK WELL CLOSER ALL
THEIR SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ADDED AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SIX AND SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN. ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY MARCH TENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH
ELEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH TWELFTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASS
AND RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER COOPER MOVE SAID MR
LACKEY SECONDS. THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH FIFTH. AT NINE AM OF THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.